[Music]
this is star talk sports edition i'm
neil degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
take a deep dive into the waters of ted
lasso
10 lasso uh if you haven't seen it on
apple plus it's a it's a tv series but
why it interests us in particular is
because there's a lot of psychology sort
of neuroscience going on in that show
ted lasso is a coach
an american coach coaching a uk football
team
soccer team and there's a lot of
interpersonal dynamics that brings them
to this program and anytime we have
neuroscientist issues we bring in
heather berlin she'll come in actually
in the third segment of this program but
in the meantime let me first introduce
my to co-host chuck nice check hey neil
i gotta tell ya all right dive into the
waters of ted lasso sounds very erotic i
like it
okay
everything is that way to you
uh and we also we also of course have
gary o'reilly gary
always good to have you there a former
professional soccer player in the uk
yeah so this is right
right down your alley here now of course
uh in order to make this work
it would it'd be better if we had like
folks from the show so why not so we
invited and they agreed to appear
to the co-creators of the show jason
sedakis and brendan hunt guys welcome to
star talk sports edition hello thanks
for having me here all right excellent
excellent jason you and i met some years
ago i think we just crossed paths in a
in a sound studio but it was it was a
fun a fun encounter and i'm i'm i don't
know if i can officially call you a
friend of mine but you're you're
somebody i watch and follow and it's
always great to see you uh doing very
cool interesting things comedic and
dramatic and the like but so thanks for
being on the uh on the show so the two
of you guys created this sort of
fictitious
character
uh playing for a fictitious premier
league football club and
it's the show is is is globally
famous on many levels and so what we
want to know is
uh how is it that
ted lasso this character who is a is a
he's a coach
but he's got he's just
really really a nice guy and it's like
no these people don't exist they should
they exist should there be a law against
them why and then somehow
it works and it works convincingly not
in some weird fantasy way
and so so we're going to delve into
the the
the
how you guys turn ted lasso into a
modern-day superhero with a different
portfolio of powers that we normally
find the power of marvelness
power of kindness so let me lead off
with with chuck and gary because they've
been thinking about this like uh ever
since we first floated the idea so gary
i'm gonna let gary go first but i gotta
say this before we start before we start
i just gotta get this out of the way
you know for for brian and jason um uh
this is a thank you from from brendan
i'm sorry brendan not brian brennan i'll
get brian in here too though we'll get
this straight
in here
i don't even know why i brought him up
thank you
brandon brendan's so much cooler but
thank you to you guys from the rest of
the world for making america give a damn
about uh soccer because
seriously yeah blasphemy
without this show man seriously it's
like i've never seen more people get
into soccer because of you two
that's the stealth mission
there you go
now they know the ball is inflated and
not stuffed there you go
baby steps baby steps babysitting this
is the trojan horse we're actually just
trying to get soccer going out there
good grow the family so okay chaps here
we go um
strength
listen to that
they're anglicized brian get your chats
on
humankind's success has been on
community and cooperation yeah you put
ted
in the
all about me
rolls royce us and them ferrari world of
premier league football
and
you repeatedly demonstrate
how we find common ground i mean what on
earth inspired you to do that
golly i mean i i think you know brent
and i both come from um
you know a background in improv uh
improvisational comedy which is you know
as as much of you know playing on a you
know
a team you know playing team sports as
much as you know working in in some
environment you know a chosen family
environment and just that whole notion
of you know yes and is like you you know
sort of um
you know like almost like a prayer in
improv you know where you accept an idea
you support the idea and then you add to
it and so i think it was just rooted in
the way that we all we we played
together specifically brendan and i and
our buddy joe kelly who we did these
commercials back in 2013 and 2014 where
that's where the character initially
started and even the way we went about
making those commercials for nbc sports
you know with with the tottenham
hotspurs and and uh etc we didn't write
a script you know and this isn't a thing
that we invented i mean they do this all
the time on like shows like enthusiasm
etc where we just had like beats written
out but this was like a multi
multi-million dollar
like you know ad campaign and we were
just i wouldn't say we were winging it
because there was absolute intention
behind everything we were doing we just
didn't have a hard copy of the script
that people were going through and we
just trusted each other and we knew that
if brenda and i knew we were making joe
laugh
and i was making brennan and joe laugh
and brennan was making joe and i laughed
then you just when you have that alchemy
of a little triangle you just know that
there's good stuff happening there and
so we just sort of followed
that and so it was made in kindness with
friends and then that just like it was
sort of in the dna of the thing it we
didn't know we were doing it the very
especially the very first one that it
was that it was about because i would
say the first commercial isn't about
kindness it wasn't until we got to the
second one that really unlocked ted's
optimism and and um you know hopefulness
uh and his you know curiosity and
whatnot um and then by the time a couple
years after that when we started talking
about the tv show it we were really
as a country like
being inundated with a lot of negativity
i mean little did we know how far you
know the the prime example of of you
know
uh ignorance and arrogance hadn't quite
come down the you know the the escalator
in trump uh plaza yet but it was it was
there was a disturbance in the force and
so we wanted to make a show that didn't
rely on
sarcasm and cynicism i know i personally
didn't want to play a character that
would have felt derivative to david
brent or michael scott you know uh you
know all these great characters that
were uh you know kicking butt on
television so it was really about what
we didn't want to do and it lent itself
time and time again to you know kindness
and and to like
empathy words that we i don't think we
were necessarily aware of you know i
mean aware of yes but but i weren't
speaking about in in the writers room or
even in in my my dining room
at my house in brooklyn joe and brenda
and i sort of beat out the idea for this
for the show so i got to compliment you
as a scientist for
viewing your your your sort of comedic
commercial spots as
tests you're testing the ideas 100
percent 100
yeah it's science yeah if you haven't
you got to test it otherwise you know
can we get a sense
can we get a sense of uh
the the meeting where uh this
multi-million dollar project uh fronted
by nbc and they asked for the script
review
um well the version of it is
it's like hey
hey brendan jason uh you know we we gave
you a few million dollars
can we say this could we see the script
they didn't give that million dollars to
us my man that was entirely for the
purposes of the nbc's networks and reach
outs but um what we didn't know about
this meeting but this meeting kind of
happened but we are at the tottenham
hotspur training center we are in our rv
me and joe and jason and jeff uh jason's
manager we're playing catan
and uh and we're watching literally
playing some japan
yeah we're remember we watched a ton of
uh coming to america like just clips
from coming to america just like on
youtube we were just like we were
passing time meanwhile outside this van
go ahead brendan yeah like between
setups like we've done one bit we're
gonna do the next bit and we told them
like oh yeah we'll do like ted like uh
in uh like playing fifa so set that up
we'll be there
and
they don't work that way so outside this
you know rv of fun
dozens of english crew members are just
like
what's happening
sounds about right for the english yeah
crew members but also nbc exactly sports
executives you know like people being
like what like dude what is going on
what are they doing and we're just in
there just you know i'll trade you wood
for for you know for sheep you know and
sellers have good just just like
children
you know and again but but but not being
arrogant about it you know like just
just we didn't know any better it was it
was our ignorance towards the process
you know and and
and and their ignorance for hiring us
so let's rewind it back to the the
psychology what expertise did you draw
from in psychology to
and we
for those of us who have watched series
one and two you persistently infuse the
plot lines with this material
do do you actually retain a mental
health professional
on the show
on the on the show no
but i think a great number of our
writing staff do personally
95
we're all in therapy everybody's in
therapy we don't have a mental health
professional
exactly yeah you know what i mean a lot
of it is rooted in in
again tenants of improvisation which
which have you know
um
you know very macro view versions of of
you know
and different sayings you know follow
the follower you know like
you know yes i am those notions but then
then there was you know i would found
the writings and the the philosophy of
john wooden the the great ucla college
basketball coach um to be profound and
that and his his his
philosophies were things that i used to
teach when i coached
improv teams and and taught improv
and his pyramid of success was something
that that i thought really broke down
nicely to how to how an individual can
conduct themselves within a group
dynamic and be take care of themselves
but then also support the people with
them which is really you know an idea i
ideal
your head space to be in when when you
know making stuff up on the fly you know
much less life you know driving on the
highway you know anything where you're
dealing with the two of you as
with comedic chops um and i think jason
didn't you have a stint on saturday
night live i have something i did for i
did i was there briefly yeah yeah i hear
they like to briefly
so
so so brennan jason
good comedians
have to completely understand their
audience what they're thinking how
they're going to emote and it seems to
me
that could not to not to trivialize any
profession but that seems to me could is
half of what therapy is
knowing what the person is thinking
because if you don't you're just
shooting in the dark and the and the way
you've been you you've scripted
yourselves and the way you interact
there's always a little bit of insight
into what's going on in the person's
head and so you're telling us that that
comes to you from your comedic um
backgrounds
i'd say and like i'm not sure that we
know what our audience is thinking so
much as we give our audience a lot of
credit you know we we just expect that
our audience is
is is bright and um as as i have saying
that i've heard in improv the audience
doesn't get what they want the audience
wants what they get
um so if we just assume that they're
bright and they'll go along with us and
if we're doing if we're doing our best
then they're they're more likely to go
along with us so that's all we can worry
about there i think
by the way brendan that's my same
philosophy on christmas for my children
just to let you know
you want what you get
[Laughter]
mariah carey we have a rewrite on your
hits on your christmas anthem
my favorite quote that's exactly in line
with that that was one that doug close
said who's like you know improv guru who
who i got the you know study with in the
late 90s in chicago was like if you
treat your audiences like poets and
geniuses they will rise to the occasion
and so so it really is less thinking
about it's less thinking about what are
they going to get this are they going to
do that we we
in every step of the process of creating
the show
we have been cognizant and intentional
about leaving space for people to lean
into it whether it be the you know
brandon joe and i the fellow writers our
fellow co-creator bill lawrence let him
lean into it because he's done thousands
of hours of television he knows the form
so well and so we want our actors to
lean into it to not just we're not
they're not action figures that we're
puppeteering and like you have to say
the words just like this you know we
have every actor lean in you know uh
because we're americans and and you know
the anglicized things like oh we don't
we don't say it that way we said we like
we had the word ma'am because you know
ted said ma'am in the pilot so much and
the very first time
uh jeremy swift who played higgins
called uh rebecca welton ma'am it
sounded like mom and i was like oh
that's a different show that's a
different show we can't have that
and and we and we do that with the prop
department the the hair makeup people
everybody we leave space and we try to
do that for the audience too where
i think some of the things you might be
picking up neil you know
not to talk about how the sausage is
made too much but from my money we're
really
in the editing process we want to people
to we want people to see
the actors say the lines and for people
to receive the line then show the actor
receiving that line too because i feel
that's how we watch things at home like
we're all listening to each other now
and that's the that for me is the 50
that uh you know sometimes when you have
to you know on network television you
have to get to the commercial breaking
you only have like 20 minutes to tell
this three act story we had the luxury
of not having to follow that that
paradigm because of being on streaming
and being on apple tv plus and them
accommodating our you know
the the style we're trying to do where
it wasn't boom boom boom we want to live
leave space and grace for people to lean
in and you know hear and receive the
information in
in time with the people we're going to
take our first break in a couple of
minutes but let me just add to that if
you're giving me room to participate in
the emotions of what you've written it
is working because
every episode
that i've watched
i there's some moment when i well up
there's some tender moment i get a
little teary emotionally teary and that
wouldn't happen unless you you
you invited me into what's going on
and so i i'm feeling like and if you
weren't willing to be invited i mean
that's you know
kicking and screaming i don't want to
cry stop it
right
gary you got one last question before we
hit the break yeah um okay so
nice guys finish last
right we've seen teams that win nasty
dirty
bend the rules break the rules whatever
you can get away with maybe if you don't
like the yankees that's the 77 and 78
yankees who won stuff and weren't liked
because of it yet you end up micro
dosing us
you give us this kind of feel-good virus
during your pandemic
i mean what about that old adage nice
guys finish last
was it an intention up front to kind of
stand it on its head
yes we i mean
100 percent
i mean i referenced like trump earlier
and i didn't mean to be you know too
cheeky about it but but
i i have found that the worst version of
a human man is
is the cocktail of someone that is you
know ignorant but arrogant you know what
i mean and you can see that played
comedically all the time you know
someone uses the word versus military
and a character is like oh yeah no i
know what that word means yeah yeah
versus military absolutely yeah yeah and
you you clearly that they don't
we wanted ted to be like hey what's that
word mean wait what verse know what you
know like like to be curious to be
ignorant which nothing wrong with that
but then to ask the question you know be
like what what's what's what's going on
there what's going on there and in the
writers room we were conscious about not
you know we were still very cynical and
sarcastic in the writers room we just we
just and those are sometimes
you know comedically um
our
first
choices and we would go to our second or
third choice we would try to make the
other choice of turning it on and said
being like okay let's not let's not be
let's not have someone to come in and go
you know nice hat you know have them
come in and be like be like like
literally that's a great hat where'd you
get that can i try it on like you know
you know
and just yes anding just supporting
whatever was going on so may i please
right now ask
what does versus militude mean
[Laughter]
we will tell chuck over the break what
very similitude means when we come back
from the break gary i want to know if
when you played were you a nice player
or a mean player
we're gonna find out when we come back
star talk sports edition and we're we're
unpacking
ted lasso and all that is and what it
means to us going forward as not only as
a show but as civilization itself
we're back star talk sports edition
we're unpacking the psychological
complexities of the hit tv series on
apple plus ted lasso and in our third
segment we're going to bring on our
favorite neurologist uh neuroscientist
and and you know who she is but right
now we're in the middle of our
conversation with jason sedakis and
brendan hunt who were co-creators and
writers and actors in that series and it
contrasts really nasty people with
really friendly happy people and i just
want to know from my co-host here gary
o'reilly gary when you played soccer
were you one of the mean people or were
you one of the nice people um naughty
but nice
oh that's mean if i ever heard it oh
yeah so you
there are moments when you have to be
certain things
moments when you have to be other things
generally you would not want to hurt or
be mean or nasty but sometimes you have
to deal with it i mean there were
certain rules when i came through as a
professional player in the early stages
if their tackle came in higher you came
in higher
yes just you know the rules were survive
out there be
this is no one's going to give you an
easy passage here you're going to have
to put up and deal with it so
in certain circumstances you learn to be
but generally i was the nicer variety
but on occasion i could be
they're not so nice i don't know about
that gary you you you sound good i know
yes does my nose grow yeah man
let me just say this there's a picture
of gary running down the pitch and he's
wearing a pair of short shorts and he
looks so handsome and good like i was
attracted to you
i was looking at him and i know any man
who is wearing short shorts and looking
that confident is kind of a dick okay
it's lucky
thanks chuck this is why i don't need
enemies because i have these kind of
friends
so let me let me let me uh
broaden this this platform here there's
the the goodness in ted lasso there's
the highly varied
personality profiles of the players uh
some go through evolution others just
dip in and out of being mean and kind um
but in the end of the day we're talking
about leadership
leadership
and
is there let me just tee up the ball
with that and um you guys did
where did this notion of leadership
come from mixed in with this whole
psychological profiling of nice people
interacting with mean people some of
it's intrinsic just to the notion of
being a coach um and jason has much more
experienced athletic coaches than i do
you know i've experienced with acting
teachers and acting coaches who had an
impact but if we're making a show about
a coach you know we want that coach to
have
have an impact and and ted's brand of
leadership is how he goes about it which
as jason says is you know partially
drawn through john wooden and partially
the uh the improv coaches that we've had
um jason and if you want to get on that
yeah i mean it was really about you know
mentoring in general and then you could
even go you know zoom out even further
and say that it's about you know like
parenthood or fatherhood you know
specifically with this show but but it i
had always felt that a good mentor was
someone that saw something in you that
your baggage disallowed you to see in
yourself
you know so so oh that's beautiful yeah
that's a jason that's beautiful
thank you but i mean i've benefited from
that i've had you know you know i had a
teacher sally shipley in high school who
was like hey you you could do like this
radio tv stuff like this this this um
class we had in in um in high school
where we made like a like a weekly
television show you know like a news
show but still you could do silly stuff
like man on the street or or you know
tina fey when i showed up at snl
um
you know as a writer was like
she was like if you can improvise you
can write you know
you know
lauren hired me you know i mean i think
and i think that happens with a good you
know creative partner a good romantic
partner good coaches mentors a good
teammate you know if someone that can
say why are you being so hard on
yourself you know like
you know why aren't you seeing
for yourself what i see for you and you
that's in that's you can pair up any two
people on the show
that's what you know rebecca's doing for
keely that's what you know ted is doing
for for everyone that's what you know uh
keeley does for roy
you know it like it it it happens all
over the place and
you know we
we have the opportunity to be
you know to take life and create life
while we're here living life and why not
try to use that
you know as best as you can and think
that there's plenty there's plenty for
everyone to there's plenty of pie for
everyone to have a bite um
and that yeah it was just it was it was
rooted in that and and you know we also
wanted to mess around with the
assumptions of of toxic you know
masculinity even though we weren't
necessarily aware of that term but you
know you put it in as as you know gary
was saying like the the the ferrari you
know ego driven world
uh of
professional sports or just athletics in
general you know the preconception is
that they're all a bunch of turkeys and
like we wanted to show that yeah there
are some but they some of those people
just didn't realize that they can't be
you know a better version of themselves
and and yeah uh yeah they just want to
be encouraged several several of the
characters nearly all of the characters
at some point you dragged them through
the thistles you you put you put a
little torture twist on them
uh and on some of the conditions
in the that you show they're treatable
with medication
you know such as anxiety such as the
panic attacks but instead the show uses
therapies rather than medication um
what's the role of therapy relative to
medications have you did you think
through that sort of situation of using
therapy may be medication in the show
how did you come to that conclusion we
did have an early you know a storyline
about the roy kent character who was you
know in in the uh the autumn of his
career that maybe that was gonna lend
itself to to uh self-medicating you know
with pain pills you know and him trying
i'm gonna play one more season if i just
keep taking these you know because who
wouldn't want to be paid a bunch of
dough to play a game for a living and
and also psychologically who am i if i'm
not doing this i've done this since i
was a little boy who am i you know after
if i am not roy kent i mean that's what
you know in the ninth
episode 109 he has that whole
conversation with keely about exactly
that as he's being moved from a starter
to to uh you know a support player off
the bench and we did toy with the idea
and it we just found ourselves time and
time again
wanting to
have people to own their stuff
especially especially like men men that
have been deified made that have been
have been
uh paid well and yet they all still have
the same stuff you know and we've had
the same stuff for thousands of years
you know it's like so we wanted to keep
it at a mythological level again to
allow people you know ourselves you know
as writers and actors but then everyone
in the audience to like lean in and
maybe see
versions of themselves in these
different characters so you know you can
maybe take the journey one episode with
the keeley character and then you know
then find yourself relating more to ted
or rebecca's you know arc in a different
episode but we just wanted people to
care about these people so that the
smallest
arc
like mattered you know it doesn't have
to be saving the world it could be just
saving saving face you know or saving
their own heart in in that moment and i
think that to do it without drugs to try
to do it within oneself is what the
whole second season is about and the
first season really about you know
realizing that you can lean on others um
the the first season so like the the you
know human element and and the you know
the the healing powers of one another
versus uh you know very
you know like medication is super
helpful to you know super but it's not
as
um
probably it's not as fun to write you
know opens pills
unless the medication is abused right if
it's just taken then nobody has any
problems you've got nothing to write
about yeah yeah and where about 95 of
our writing staff has a psychologist i
think we're a solid 60 has a
psychiatrist too yeah so we're not
taking some stand here by any means yeah
yeah yeah right and that's the funny
thing about you know when you're taking
psych psychiatric uh
um medication is that when you take it
it just works and nobody knows you're
taking it it's actually kind of boring
i will say that that you know a book
that came out right as we were writing
the pilot was how to change your mind by
michael pollan who who's talking about
the use of you know um psilocybin and
lsd and and mdma as a way to treat ptsd
to treat depression to treat anxiety and
and so ted was in we spoke about a lot
you know me brendan joe and bill
lawrence would uh about ted being the
personification of mushrooms you know
that there was an egolessness that he
carries that when someone it presents
themselves to him and they're angry
like he knows that it's not about them
like it's he's just a mirror for for
that right then you know it's like it's
like
uh you know you never know what what
battle someone's dealing with you know
inside their own you know head heart and
soul and so we just wanted to
with ted was an opportunity to personify
that and and he's almost like a weeble
wobble if you remember those toys
growing up you know like you know they
get knocked down they get right back up
and it feels funny because in today's
day and age especially again you know
over these last six years it was about
fighting back punch back you know hit
back harder like that became language
yeah you know what you just made me
think of something that is um
just a great representation of that in
actual sports i love watching the nfl
when they put the microphones on the
guys and you see them on the field right
and you would think that they're out
there just like i'm gonna kill you i'll
rip your nuts off
right
but
when you listen to them often
they're talking to their opponent and
they're just they're they don't help
each other up they used to do that but
they don't now
coaches stop that but they look at each
other and they go all right buddy hey
man that was okay hey good good good one
man that was good man all right i'll see
what you did i see what you did there
let's meet again right we'll see each
other next time like they're not like
i'm going to kill you it really is a
positive experience and exchange you
know it's it's pretty wild yeah let me
tell you more it's more guaranteed yeah
i'll tell you now when you're mic'd up
you don't say none of that other stuff
when that max on someone else are you
just going to put i am going to pull
your head out
i am going to stick it in a bag and i'm
taking it home with me yeah so you're
saying they're acting
i'm wearing a wire
so so brandon let me i got another
question here
i was very happy
the entire first season watching ted
lasso be
coach therapist basically all right he
was coach and part-time therapist
dealing with this
conflagration of personalities
but then you bring in an actual
therapist and i thought to myself what's
coach lasso gonna do
does he have any job left now and then
we find out that he could benefit from
some therapy so i what was what was
going on
in the in the decision to bring on an
actual professional therapist
and a sports therapist even not just a
random person off the out of the catalog
yeah um i think uh a few things went
into it um so i don't want to speak for
jason here too much because but one
thing that was big in my mind was that
you know in season one we show ted
having panic attacks and um and that's
uh that's a that's a big thing and
i personally kind of felt like it would
be irresponsible of us to just kind of
let that have floated out there like
some kind of plot point for a couple of
episodes as opposed to being something
that indicated there was a larger thing
to address
so
then it became how to address it and
yeah there's there's just a lot of teams
right now even even in england with all
of its stigmas about mental health even
in england plenty of teams now have a uh
have a sports therapist on
the on the side oh it's a regular thing
okay it's becoming more and more yeah
people are people are much more aware of
it's not just your body it's the space
between your ears that's really quite
vital what what i'm interested in
because wait wait gary i have brains
between my ears not space
that's because you
have
astrophysics going on
i have more space in here than probably
i should
just saying i'm just saying
you know that's what it is so
in in a dressing room a locker room in a
premier league team
group dynamic
is not everything but it's so vital
you've got your individual components
because there's always a star
then you need a couple of water carriers
then you need someone solid and
dependable and you've got all of this
going on
and if you do not manage that whilst
managing all of the other individual
component parts it falls apart quickly
that was my experience in clubs that i
played with so how did you going into
that
look to see where you could mine
your storylines
i mean a lot more we're trojan horsing
our own personal philosophies and
stories you know one of the nice things
about writing a show about you know
in this tone which you know about
not about but deals with you know and
set in the realm of kindness and empathy
is that our writer's room was very it
was everybody was was open-hearted and
and shared their experiences of dealing
with you know within their own family
you know within within other
you know work situations you know uh
possibly if people played you know
sports or did anything ensemble based
and you just kind of find out
you know when you do like a show like
this and you have people from different
walks of life of how similar they are
and how much things overlap and you're
kind of like oh we call that something
different but yeah we got that we do
that and that was one of the neat things
about the show finally coming out was
then we had people like for us to have
brenda and i to have the opportunity to
you know do brene brown's podcast and
all of her you know ackman and and skill
set in in explaining like vulnerability
and the vocabulary she used to explain
the show back to us in a very like not
aerodyne way but like with vocabulary
that we never would have thought of in a
million years it felt very similar to
taking improv classes where it's like oh
you're that's what it's called when i
play like this you know as a kid oh i
okay so i'm i'm heightening i just
thought i was just making it funnier you
know it's like you know that's called
height you know it's given it gives you
vocabulary for it you know in a way that
we
you know we just really leaned on each
other and relied on each other and and
felt
vulnerable enough in the writers room to
to share that and then once again when
you get to the actors then they put
their own experiences into it so it's
really about just taking our own stuff
and just you know hiding it in these
people
and that strikes me that that that's a
big part of what therapy is is giving
the vocabulary to describe stuff you
know it's starting from we're trying to
do this with kids now like would you
having a feeling right now that we have
to try to be able to
describe for you and you know maybe
where a lot of people get into trouble
is that they're just going through stuff
that they can't even describe and the
more we can let people
describe what they're going through
maybe it'll be easier for them to deal
with it you know it's funny i'm i'm
listening to all of you right now that
you keep this
these words keep coming up during this
conversation vulnerability and support
and like you know teammates and
you know therapists and it just occurred
to me that you cannot give or receive
support without being vulnerable
because if you're giving support you
have to trust you have to be vulnerable
and open to trust that person to help
them and if you're receiving it you have
to be that much more vulnerable and open
to receive it so
it's uh it's actually a pretty brilliant
construct for a sports um you know arena
i i just love it
it's the thing is chuck if you travel
back to my time as a player
you dealt with it on your own right
there was no safety net there wasn't a
therapist right you didn't want to talk
to people around you because you would
be weak
and the whole thing about being a
professional athlete in an ultra
competitive environment is you are
strong
and show weakness
and then everybody just you know you you
generally don't play 100 fit in fact
you'd never play 100 fit right you're
always carrying some kind of injury
physically now adding to the component
of mental problems the things can really
and you talk about how players go out of
form and cannot deliver
there's a lot of things going on now as
as we understand there are therapists
around
to identify certain issues rather than
have this person fall apart in front of
you hey let me ask you this then all of
you all of you let me ask you this
because we're all running short on time
are we running short on time so if you
make it make it quick i'm gonna make it
real quick make it quick okay because it
looks like we're all from the same
generation of suck it up as far as i can
sell yeah all right so how do you feel
about these athletes now who basically
say look my mental health is more
important than um you know achieving the
win
frankly yeah you got you got to support
you got to support it i i think you know
and different strokes for different
folks but i'm not gonna
it's hard it's really hard you know and
and then you know
to have social media be not so social
sometimes
yeah
you know a bunch of strangers popping
off at you and telling you you ain't
this you ain't that like you know how
dare you it's like you do it
you try it like i don't want to be that
guy you know towards you know any young
man or woman these are also people the
majority of them are also
25 or young kids like right yeah like
you know not even fully formed
so
we've got to close out this segment and
actually say goodbye to jason and
brandon but i just want to uh
just comment that
in a very tight format of this program
you managed to successfully go in and
out of and explore
every permutation of human dynamics and
relationships and and only after i
solved watched it did i say wow we just
talked about boyfriend girlfriend mother
father son daughter uh children uh old
people young people death
you know birth right it's all of that's
in there it's like how did they do that
how did they do that
you know and and and and and you made me
care about them and you're making me cry
every episode so stop it
no telling you that no
no no
my permission to carry on
just saying
brandon and jason jason first it's great
to see you again dude likewise and um
brandon it was uh great to meet you
for the first time here and good luck
with more seasons of the show you
clearly teed up another season in that
last episode of season two and so we're
all waiting for that to drop uh so uh
it's great just best to you keep keep up
with the comedy uh we on star talk we're
big fans of comedy here and we know that
comedians hold the
the spirit
energy and the soul of what makes
civilization work and so
all of life is not just drama you have
to smile every now and then and you guys
know that that formula and recipe and
you're inventing new formulas as you go
along so dudes uh thanks for being on
star talk absolutely thanks for having
us thank you doctor all right
when we come back we're gonna go to
we're going to heather heather berlin
uh she's our neuroscientist
uh in residence and she's gonna unpack
this episode as it has unfolded thus far
on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition we
were unpacking the psychological
dimensions of ted lasso the apple plus
tv hit series that's all about sort of
an american coach
in the uk coaching soccer need to know
anything about soccer and so it becomes
a story about
managing
egos and
how to be kind and the power of kindness
kindness as a superpower even
and we had jason sedakis and brendan
hunt
the two co-creators on and we learned a
lot but we're going to learn some more
because we're going to our
neuroscientist at large
heather berlin heather welcome back to
star talk for the hundredth time always
a pleasure always a pleasure thanks for
having me
okay
yeah yeah so gary you know took the lead
on this because that boy here did played
some actual talker in the uk
so gary why don't you lead off here with
what questions you have for heather okay
um
welcome heather to this particular
edition of star talk sports edition um
please explain to us and particularly me
what reactions go off in the brain
when it's involved in an act of kindness
because you've got the giver and the
receiver
and
can you just explain what is going on so
as i can
understand a little bit better and is it
better to give than it is to receive
well in a
in an interesting way you know giving or
being kind is actually in some ways a
selfish act because you're really
ultimately you're helping yourself as
well
and we can see that in all sorts of
changes in terms of neurochemistry
being kind can decrease your cortisol
levels and stress hormones which is good
for the brain it releases oxytocin
which is this very um pleasurable
bonding hormone that's also released
when you're in love it's released when a
mother is breastfeeding her child which
promotes bonding it's released during
sex uh it releases dopamine which is a
pleasure sort of uh neurotransmitter in
the brain activates the pleasure centers
of the brain you get increases in uh
serotonin which helps regulate your mood
so you know across the board it actually
is really not only good for your
physical health but also for your
psychological health um so so in many
ways it is much better to give than it
is to receive although receiving feels
nice and that is also pleasurable but
there's something in particular in the
act of giving in the act of kindness
that that's almost um better than
actually receiving something
so it's symbiotic
if it's actually a selfish act then i'm
just going to start giving stuff to
myself
because then i'm getting double the
benefits i'm the giver of the receiver
but you know how you can't tickle
yourself right because you're expecting
it right only you can only get tickled
by others so there's it's not the same
just technically speaking giving to
yourself is not the same because you're
expecting it and it changes the way your
brain responds to it just like you can't
tickle yourself so i'm going to have to
say
that's that's your idea so now i'm going
to learn to tickle myself yeah so so
heather
okay so we as we've been discussing with
jason and brendan you know ted was micro
dosing us with kindness
as an audience
yes so what is an audience were we
feeling and how because this just thing
just sort of crept up on us i've been
like a stealthy little
series and got us so what's going on
when you
witness these acts of kindness over and
over and over again well i think you
know just in terms of the ethos of what
was happening in society at the time you
know being in the midst of a pandemic
having lots of sort of um narcissistic
leaders um at the helm this was sort of
a um
you know showing us a glimpse again
reminding us of the other side of
humanity you know it was cathartic i
think for people it also he was a role
model in many ways not just for his
teammates but for all of us you know
handing out these words of wisdom you
know these gems these coping mechanisms
um
uh showing us that you can succeed
in helping people and having more of a
cohesive environment rather than being
against one another so i think all of
those things were were very needed and
are very needed
not only when the show comes out but you
know forever more um
but the idea of this selflessness too of
you know connecting in other people it's
not about you it's about the other
person and empathy and compassion and
just reminding us that these are also
human traits
in addition to the you know more
negative ones that we've been seeing a
lot um recently heather i have a quote
from william shakespeare
and it's from the merchant of venice
and
let's just call it the quality of mercy
and just listen to this
the quality of mercy is not strained
it droppeth as the gentle rain from
heaven
upon the place beneath
it is twice blessed
it blesseth him that gives and him that
takes
if only that guy knew how to write that
would have been really good
that was the first draft of ted lasso
that's the merchant of venice where
there's conflict and there's or do you
have mercy are you gonna anyhow so so
heather it looks like your profession
was sort of deeply understood at least
at some level by shakespeare 400 years
ago yeah we're all just following his
lead obviously um yeah so what do we
need you for
okay
how it works at the normal level
heather um is there is there a point
where positivity
becomes toxic
and it can't be sustained within an
individual within a group
and then sometimes you just have to get
angry to get something going in the
right direction yeah i like that
question yeah yeah i think positivity
yeah who decided that happy people is
the goal who
why is should that be the objective here
maybe if they're all angry with each
other that would boil their blood and
they'd go out and perform even better
who are we to say that happy is good
there's an element in the show where
they where you know roy
says we need to get jamie a little bit
aggressive at one point because he needs
some of that in order to perform well in
season two jamie the player
yeah um so
yes there is too much there can be toxic
sort of positivity you know when
positivity is overused or as a defense
mechanism which also
happens to ted um where you don't
actually ever deal with the negative
emotions and you're just using this
positivity to sort of as a shield
um that that's that can be maladaptive
we evolve negative emotions for a reason
right we it would be maladaptive to not
have any of them right pain helps keep
us from you know like bumping into
things and knocking our arm off right we
need pain um to protect us we need
anxiety or else we'd be doing really
risky things without any forethought
right so these these feelings are
important and we need to
there was this film inside out this
pixar film where you know they just
wanted happiness to win they were
looking at all the emotions at the end
realizing
no you really need both in order to have
happiness you need to have sadness so um
anything that is gone to the extreme can
tend to be maladaptive um and but but
happiness in moderation i think is a
good thing heather i love that i love
that yeah i love that heather so can you
experience
uh positive and negative emotions
sympathetically like watching a
television show to make you more
positive or negative
so in order in other words can
a television show elicit these feelings
within yourself
right causing you to be more of that or
less of that yeah there are these
knock-on effects so you know for example
um one study had people um while they
were in the scanner looking at brain
activation viewing neutral scenes and
then viewing aggressive um scenarios and
when they were just simply watching like
a film about aggression it decreased
activation in their prefrontal cortex
which is their sort of impulse control
part of the brain and therefore you know
if they then were to go outside right
after watching the show they might have
a tendency to be have less impulse
control um but the same thing with
eliciting emotions of joy as well so
your brain you know we have these mirror
neurons which are kind of like in some
ways some things are involved in empathy
um when we are having an emphasis we
call them mirror
mirror neurons mirror neurons yes
which which really uh mimic other
people's movements um and some people
think they're about how you learn things
it's very much involved in modeling
behavior and learning and and some link
it to empathy as well but in some ways
you're actually enacting that experience
um there's an empathy network in your
brain that gets activated there's this
really interesting study with olfaction
where they collected stressful sweat
from people about to jump out of an
airplane or take a stressful exam and
neutral sweat when people were working
at the gym and then they gave them to
other people to smell and they couldn't
consciously take a difference
but when they were in the scanner when
they gave them the stress sweat it
activated their empathy network of the
brain so there are these signals coming
into us whether it's olfaction or things
that we're viewing that can actually
activate these empathy networks and
cause us to go on and be kinder
our behavior is affected by all sorts of
things because you know in the brain it
doesn't know what's real and what's not
it's just you know ones and zeros it's
just information bits of information so
whether you're really engaged in a happy
situation or you're just watching it on
tv the brain can experience it
in a very similar way can i trick my
brain because sometimes you get yourself
up for a performance for your your event
your game
and then you have to bring yourself down
i mean here's stories of michael jordan
used to create something just so as he
could that would help him energize and
it was a fictitious thing he'd said
someone had said something and it would
raise his game
what are we doing in that are we able to
kind of dial up dial down with will
i think yes um
you know in so far as you have certain
neural sort of networks that are wired
up in your brain in a certain way and
you have certain structures that have
developed in a certain way so you have
certain limitations
right but you can dial yourself up to
your highest end of let's say
performance with certain limits even
with you know they looked at people who
did these heroic acts like in the moment
um and they found that they often and
they interviewed them after like
strangers helping strangers suddenly and
they find that the people who did these
heroic acts actually have larger
amygdala um this sort of emotional
center of the brain
than other people who didn't uh have do
these heroic acts so they actually have
structural differences in their brain
and they found that when they responded
they didn't think about it it was
automatic so there are these automatic
responses that we have so you can train
yourself yes to an extent but there are
other things that are just really innate
and they also found these heroic people
that they had um
more responsive amygdala when they saw
people in distress and with sociopaths
for example they don't get that amygdala
reaction they can see someone you know a
picture of someone being murdered or
babies chopped up or horrible things and
they don't get that amygdala response so
i think with anything you can train your
brain to a certain point but if you just
don't have that innate sort of structure
um or neural network or wiring let's
call it um it can be much more difficult
is there such a thing as an amygdala
hijack
hi jackie and the amygdala yeah
yeah so what what takes place
in that scenario is it the opposite to
what you've just described
you mean somebody something taking over
your emotional responses yeah um you
know if something that's called marriage
you know when people when you have a
particular trigger and i think with ted
lasso too you know um
there are certain things that would
trigger these panic attacks right and
that in a way is is hijacking these
amygdala it's tapping into your what we
call the sympathetic nervous system and
putting it in high gear whereas other
people can have the same experience for
them it might not do anything to them
but if you have a history and certain
trauma then you'll have these triggers
that can just sort of um flip the switch
and put you into this high like
fight-or-flight response could you
comment on some of the drugs that got
mentioned so psilocybin was one of them
i think yeah
and i love this where can i get it where
can i get it
i love the idea of ted being stopped i
got a guy i got a guy there's not a guy
on the corner we know you have we
holding out heather we know you're
holding man
uh no so i love the idea of you know how
he mentioned that ted was like the
personification of
mushrooms and we're so we're using
psychiatry now psilocybin um the
ingredient in psychedelic mushrooms are
being used to help treat depression and
anxiety and we're trying to understand
what's happening in the brain and why
does it have such a profound effect and
one of the things is that your ego in
some ways dissolves so this boundary
between self and other that we all
normally have comes to disappear or and
some people say your ego actually
expands so that everyone is a part of it
but this idea of then being one with
everyone or everything and feeling their
pain makes you less judgmental makes you
sort of more empathetic understanding
where they're coming from and therefore
be better positioned to be able to help
them because you're not coming at it
with what's in it for me or with your
own biases it's your true openness and i
love that idea this metaphor with with
ted being like
on a permanent kind of mushroom trip
without the psychedelic effect but the
idea is that he's in some ways egoless
in the way he you know people are
insulting him all the time whatever he's
just not taking it personally he
understands where they're coming from
and and doesn't react in ways like that
are aggressive or defensive and i think
that's just such a beautiful metaphor
but that's one of the ways that you know
from a science perspective one of the
reasons why we think
mushrooms are so helpful to help
transform permanently transform
someone's perspective and give them an
insight just like the overview effect of
astronauts you know when they see space
earth from space they suddenly have this
profound shift in their consciousness
we're all in it together and it's the
same thing that can happen with if you
are permanently selfless and feel this
connection with everyone else
so what about leadership is that
something you're you're born with or you
develop it
can you tell who's a leader by scanning
their brain and what drug do you need
for that
there are no
there are any there are some personality
differences that would make someone be a
better leader or a more natural leader i
wouldn't say that there's one thing in
the brain that you can sort of discern
okay that like put them in category this
would be a good leader this wouldn't but
a certain constellation of personality
types and also depending on what kind of
leadership you're talking about you know
so so you know a leader could be a
kindergarten teacher you know who's
helping children in this way and being a
role model or it could be the ceo of you
know
a a financial institution and they're
going to be different essential
qualities that are needed to lead in
those in those particular areas but the
idea that there's
sometimes when there's a sort of
stressor a natural leader comes and
rises up to meet the occasion um and
usually it's somebody that has a lot of
um either has had experience with trauma
in the past and knows how to cope when
things get really difficult and
stressful um or it's somebody who's just
very very grounded and has a very clear
vision of what needs to be done and like
where others can be sort of uncertain
and there's some chaos somebody might
rise up that says okay i can show you
the way i have a very clear picture of
what's happening but all of those things
it's a it's really a mishmash of a lot
of different personality traits that's
hard to say you know this is the one
thing that makes you a good leader
so some people lead because they have a
power and a force within them that
people respond to but other people lead
because
people just want to follow them
right there is no sort of aggression
there there it's just
wow that's an interesting i'm going to
follow that person and so my sense is
that the ted lasso character
is is not one of these i'm at the top
and you're not follow me because you
must
it's i'm going to say some things and
you're going to realize it's really cool
and it's going to work and he lets them
take ownership of their own revelations
and that seems to me to be a rather
potent pathway so you know what's
interesting about that neil there is a
coaching term in football called guided
discovery
where you take a player and you show
them something technical
and you kind of get to a certain point
and leave the rest for them to discover
for themselves
so knowing all along where they're gonna
wear their heads yeah you know you you
know you want them to be at this point
you take them so far and then when they
get there they are so better for the
fact that they feel they've completed
the thing themselves without you showing
everything to them and saying this is
what you gotta do do do do you take them
so far then the rest and it empowers
them to like that idea they take
they take ownership of their own talent
at that point yep there's two they're
inside there's a scientific theory about
this sort of um attaining high status
which would be sort of being a leader
that people look up to and want to
follow and there's two different
pathways to get there and one is the
dominance path you know that's like the
stalin and you know we can name a whole
list of people um and using cohort
coercion and
all sorts of things to get power and
other is the prestige path they call but
that is
just having being good at something
having an internal quality like with ted
he didn't rule in a strong way he had
wisdom and after a while people said oh
maybe this guy knows something maybe
he's on to something you know rebecca's
having problems with her mother she
wants him to come to lunch because maybe
he'll have some insights and so
sometimes we we relate as we see
something special in a person and say oh
that's someone i can learn from from and
then they start to gain status and
prestige and sort of you know rise up in
the hierarchy so you can either take
power or you can earn it by just being
really good at something that people
admire but we got to bring this to a
close so heather always good to have
your insights and perspectives thanks
for being such a friend of star talk
here and gary great hearing you from the
horse's mouth there you're welcome my
friend
you know soccer is still a little bit of
a mystery to we americans and you're
getting that here you're you're getting
there you're yeah it's slow we're we're
we're we're interested quicker than you
think you're getting there quicker than
you think
the the women's team is stella chuck
always good to have you man always a
pleasure
this has been star talk sports edition
unpacking ted lasso and i'm neil
degrasse tyson as always beating you to
keep looking up
[Music]
you